première invitée de ce set 8 quand le
livre bonsoir bonsoir casque audio de
l'ump est lancé dans les yvelines on a
l'habitude de recevoir sur son plateau
aurore bergé cas l'ambition de faire
basculer la commune socialiste de magny
les hameaux du côté de l'ump vous c'est
un peu le même objectif impôts si oui
depuis depuis 2008 et est cette fusion
un petit peu atypique entre le ps et
modem qui a fait basculer la ville de
poissy à à 250 voix on s'est mis on
s'est mis en place sur la ligne de
départ d'un marathon en fait un marathon
qui dure donc depuis de pizza est
commencée depuis 2008
en fait parce que voilà on sentait que
de toute façon un modem plutôt de centre
droit avec eux une équipe socialiste
puis des verts dedans c'était une idée
bulleuse qui à mon sens n'allait pas
aller très loin il se trouve que six
mois après les socialistes ont décidé de
tout simplement de virer le modem avec
lesquels il avait fait équipe donc on
est dans un espèce de no man's land
pillay avait un chemin de traverse à
emprunter de façon pragmatique sur le
terrain c'est ce que un bleu munger et
tenter de faire avec mon équipe
vous avez été élu conseiller général en
2011 2011
ça nous suffit pas mr c'est
complémentaire ou c'est non je crois que
d'abord n'y a pas de calcul par rapport
par rapport à cela catherine l'idée
c'est d'abord vraiment une approche je
pense pragmatique sur le sur le terrain
en 2011 par exemple j'ai tout simplement
dit aux gens voilà vos enfants sont nés
à la crèche c'est une prérogative du
conseil général jusqu'au soir où vos
grands parents sont dans une résidence
pour personnes âgées
c'est du domaine du conseil général à
partir du moment où vous dites aux gens
ce que vous êtes capables de leur
apporter mais également ce que vous ne
pouvez pas faire alors les gens
l'entendent
j'ai fait 63 % à la cantonale de 2011
mais l' approche pragmatique et est la
même avec celui qui fera également
partie de la liste david douillet en
2009 à l'âge législatives et en 2012
également halal législatif rigueur
puisque vous parlez david oui on en
parlait
annoncé sur une candidature à rouen
finalement il trace à votre liste
numéro 3 oui c'est effectivement sur la
sur la liste il ya vraiment jamais eu
trop d'actualité par rapport à rang il
trouve que david à sa g en main en cuir
qui l'a élevé qui habite à rouen donc
depuis plusieurs mois parce qu'elle est
pas bien il fait plusieurs allers
retours mais david et à poissy
d'implanter à poissy ont fait équipe
avec david ont fait équipe avec jean
françois raynal qui est le conseil
général de poissy nord avec toutes
celles et ceux qui veulent que poissy
change et la bonne nouvelle date d'hier
soir catherine c'est que arnaud richard
qui a été fraîchement élu président
départemental de lui dès ce week-end a
annoncé effectivement son soutien à ma
candidature soutient déjà mes enfants
encore une fois j'aime à dire que on est
tout simplement dans le timing que nous
avions annoncée c'est un point étape il
y avait 500 personnes qui sont qui se
sont déplacés au ouais c'était un
meeting mais c'est un point d'étape
voilà et on est très content d'avoir
fait ce moment de convivialité
c'était simplement pour se retrouver et
encore une fois expliqué qu'on a un
budget dont on annonce qu'il est
vertueux alors que nous on trouve
beaucoup de vis dans ce budget et
surtout donner un formidable espoir aux
pisciacais pour leur dire qu'il ya pas
de fatalité et que demain voici peut
redevenir un poids lourd
là où aujourd'hui c'est pour nous devenu
un point mort
on l'appelle bien david douillet élu de
la 12e circonscription posée par la
députée pour ceux qui ne le savent
peut-être pas vous avez reçu récemment
sur le plateau du 7-8 vous étiez venu
parler d'un livre sur michel hidalgo
oui on vous sait très impliqué dans le
domaine du sport et du football en
particulier
alors politique sport le sport c'est
important le sport c'est l'école de la
vie
c'est à dire que dans le sport on peut
pas tricher puis je crois que le sport
c'est un formidable catalysateur de lien
social vous le savez dans le sport
retrouve du black du blanc du beurre on
trouve du patron de l'ouvrier du chômeur
et ces gens là tous ensemble quand on
porte le même maillot
on peut avoir un quart exercent sur un
thème qui sera dans la campagne
municipale pardon ça sera un thème qui
sera dans la campagne miss mama c'est
simple il n'y a pas plus de thèmes en
termes de sport que culture ou proposera
non pas une culture pour pour tous mais
une culture pour chacun mais je pense
que dès lors vous mettez en place des
règles dans quelque domaine que ce soit
que se règlent sont affichées alors un
moment donné vous êtes dans le jeu ou
alors si vous ne respectez pas les
règles
vous êtes en dehors du jeu c'est ce que
j'appelle tout simplement rétablir
rétablir l'ordre républicain à poissy
notamment au poids si on en a parlé tout
récemment dans les médias puisque c'est
la première ville des yvelines avoir
procédé à un mariage gay demain car ils
vous êtes maire de poissy dans une telle
situation vous mariez vous déléguez
écouter d'abord je veux simplement dire
que je n'aurais pas du tout procédé de
la même manière je pense qu'on avait
l'occasion comme ils le font comme nos
amis suisses le fond de faire une
votation populaire je pense que il y
aurait certainement eu moins de
problèmes dans les rues notamment
maintenant la loi est adoptée moi je
suis un élu profondément républicain je
célébrerai effectivement le mariage
homosexuel je suis totalement contre la
pma s'est pas encore à l'ordre du jour
mais je suis totalement contre
effectivement cette adoption d'accord
vous êtes aussi conseiller général oui
il ya une sorte de psychologue qui se
joue en ce moment au conseil général au
sein de la majorité
il ya une cantonale partielle qui va
avoir lieu le premier tour aura lieu le
30 juin
on va tout le monde donne tout le petit
monde politique local d'observer de cela
de près après la démission de michel
vialay puisque c'est le retour de
l'ancien président du conseil général
pierre bédier qui a été condamné en mai
2009 pour des faits de corruption
vous vous avez apporté votre soutien oui
alors il n'y a pas de franchement il
n'ya pas du tout de psychodrame vendredi
dernier après dernier il y avait une
réunion au sein du conseil général ou la
majorite' la très grande majorité a
apporté un soutien unanime à pierre
bédier
alain schmitt le président en tête bien
évidemment aujourd'hui on a un vrai
enjeu c'est le développement de l'axé
seine et j'en sais quelque chose pour
habiter je reviens sur ma question sur
le soutien que vous apportez à pierre
bédier vous apporter un soutien total
moi j'apporte y apporte un soutien total
au total à pierre bédier juste pour vous
dire que l'axonais est important et la
région et le mantois
c'est un axe sensible par rapport à
cette conquête de l'axé seine
à ce titre-là des leurs ou michel vialay
a décidé de démissionner de son poste de
conseiller général le meilleur candidat
aujourd'hui éligibles c'est pierre
bédier il a pris a purgé sa peine ça
c'est là pas de question à se poser
c'est soit on a une vision du territoire
se sert effectivement de l'expérience
des uns pour pouvoir avancer et je pense
que c'est ça aujourd'hui qui intéresse
effectivement les aigles a l'impression
que le fait qu'il était condamné ça peut
jeter l'opprobre sur le monde
tic locale écoutez quand on a une
approche encore une fois pragmatique
elle peut être elle peut être fructifié
la réponse c'est les électeurs qui qui
la donnera à la fin du mois maintenant
je pense que la très grande majorité de
mes collègues qui sont au conseil
général qui font partie de la majorité
départementale savent ce qu'ils doivent
à pierre bédier
à titre personnel je sais ce que je dois
alain schmitt qui a toujours été très
loyal et de confiance mais à chaque jour
suffit sa peine
et pour l'heure aujourd'hui on est dans
une séquence où il ya une élection
partielle et que la famille que je
représente doit pouvoir soutenir de
façon unitaire et solidaire
notre candidat est le candidat monde
c'est pierre bédier voir si pierre
bédier est élu on conseiller général ce
que vous souhaitez qu'il retrouve son
président son fauteuil de président mais
la question n'est pas d'actualité elle
absolument pas d'actualité c'est
absolument poser ces derniers jours les
déclarations et enfin les personnes qui
se posent cette question là je crois
qu'ils n'ont pas bien compris encore le
taux de la séquence aujourd'hui lille
quoi est-ce que vous parce qu'à la
chemise cela dans les colonnes de du
parisien nos confrères du parisien
aujourd'hui a dit je ne lâcherai pas mon
fauteuil de président est ce que vous
soutenez alain schmitz et doit terminer
son mandat
on était juste a exposé du contraire
jusqu'à preuve du contraire alain
schmitt et président jusqu'en mars 2015
jusqu'à preuve du contraire pierre
bédier n'est pas encore élu alors que
pierre bédier soit élu si pierre bédier
est élu ce serait dommage de ne pas
profiter de son expérience et de sa
vision pour le territoire est de son
côté allé bagarreur compétiteurs pour
effectivement ne pas imaginer un
attelage le plus efficace qui soit entre
alain schmitt rentrer président et
pourquoi pas pierre bédier mais il y
aura peut-être d'autres forces vives
d'accord donc un retour pas présidents
vice-présidents peut-être aujourd'hui à
nabeul candidate est générale et vous
êtes du groupe f puis au conseil général
exactement si vous avez une vision que
pensez-vous en tout cas du retour de
père bd en politique c'est la question
que nous sommes allés peuvent poser à
quelques yvelines
on écoute la réponse bien sûr ça ne
dérange ou et parce que les gens qui ont
été salis qui ont fait des choses qui ne
sont pas corrects pas bien je pense ils
n'ont plus leur place en politique c'est
tout quel qu'il soit quelque bord ce
soir c'est mon avis même s'il était
blanchi bon je pense qu'il ya eu des
intentions des choses qui ne sont
certainement pas correct samedi même
s'il a été si la payer comme on dit non
pour moi ce n'est pas acceptable
il y en a même qui ont été condamnés
mais ça les a pas empêchés de revenir
s'il est blanchi qu'il a le droit de
revenir
ouais c'est un peu dérangeant quand même
parce que les sens sont censés
représenter le taillis bon donc je
trouve ça tout à fait normal s'il a été
blanchi ça ne pose aucun problème je le
connais pas personnellement mais ce que
j'ai pu lire après comme texte sur lui
ça ne me paraît pas très convaincant
donc c'est vrai que j'ai un petit peu
peur de ça as il n'a pas tort on laisse
tranquille moi je trouve que de toute
façon ils pourraient parvenir mais bon
voilà un micro trottoir réalisé à
versailles réactions devraient parvenir
c'est un peu la tonalité de la micro
trottoir pas vraiment je pense que non
mais la réponse elle appartient aux
électeurs encore une fois là quand on
écoute des morceaux choisis j'en sais
quelque chose de micro autant je sais ce
que c'est en étant mais qu'est-ce que
deux journalistes simplement juste voilà
une photographe voilà c'est une honte
c'est une photographie et moi je pense
qu'il faut pas prendre les électeurs
pour des pour des benoîts il ya une
élection on est dans un pays
démocratique
la réponse à ce micro trottoir sera
filmée devant la réponse le 30 juin pour
le premier tour devant l'autre mon tour
je rappelle qu'à six candidats en lice
dont père bédié et rama sall la
candidate souhaite une dernière question
quand même l axe l'association anticor
connaissait ses leçons de lutte contre
la corruption présidée par jean luc
trotignon elle organise une conférence
de presse ce samedi à mantes la jolie et
l'association remet en cause les excès
élections cantonales partielles en
disant ça coûte cher aux contribuables
ça coûte 70 mille euros il a besoin de
michel baylet démissionne on aurait très
bien pu attendre les échéances normales
élections bart réaction c'est que
d'abord je crois que dans la vie quand
on veut mouche et quelqu'un faut avoir
le nez propre et la deuxième chose c'est
que des élections
des élections partielles il y en a
de part et d'autre il ya une primaire
aussi du parti socialiste qui a coûté
aussi beaucoup d'argent il ya eu des
primaires à paris qu'ont coûtés aussi
beaucoup d'argent donc voilà c'est la
vie politique je pense que vouloir
cliver et stigmatisé c'est le meilleur
moyen de faire jeu des extrêmes et
aujourd'hui on en a pas besoin
d'accord donc michel vialay a eu raison
de démissionner en tout cas elle avait
ses raisons pour démissionner au bout de
son mandat
écoutez on dit parfois que c'est pas
forcément très bien que de se présenter
passer la main au cours de son mandat
quand quelqu'un a décidé d'anticiper et
de passer la main avant la fin de son
mandat parce qu'ils pensent qu'une
personne est peut-être mieux placé pour
lui d'avoir une autre vision du
territoire
à un moment donné on peut pas tout dire
tout et son contraire donc moi je me
réjouis non pas de la démission de
michel vialay quête un collègue émérite
au conseil général mais je me réjouis et
je l'espère de tout coeur de la probable
victoire de pierre bédier
dans ce secteur de vente mais faut
gagner on est compétiteur tant que le
match n'est pas terminé il n'est pas
gagné c'est fait dernière question cette
fois d'ordre national on a parlé des
municipales du conseil général on va
monter un cran nationale vous étiez le
référent de françois fillon à poissy
pour le soutenir l'élection interne de
l'ump
est-ce que vous souhaiter sa candidature
à la présidentielle en 2017 même si on
annonce peut-être un retour de nicolas
sarkozy en politique
écoutez j'ai été effectivement le
référent de françois fillon a apprécié
avec 55% des suffrages obtenus sur sur
sa candidature pour le coup je vous
cache pas que je suis je suis déçu pas
déçus de françois fillon pas déçus de
françois conclu que jean françois copé
déçu de la tournure des événements parce
que les militants sur le terrain ont
fait un boulot exceptionnel et ce qu'il
en est qui s'en est suivie ensuite
pendant des semaines et des semaines y
compris d'ailleurs les primaires auquel
on vient d'assister à paris bon c'est
pas forcément le voilà le sens est
l'exemple qu'il aurait fallu donner une
fois qu'on a dit ça
qu'est ce qu'on fait on s'arrête on
continue maintenant on continue
je pense qu'effectivement et là encore
c'est sur le terrain que ça va se passer
il est fort à parier que j'irai de façon
encore une fois pragmatique il y aura
pas de vote de nouveau vote pour pour
cette primaire et de présidence pour
pour l'ump
et puis ensuite tranquillement on est
aujourd'hui en 2000 en 2013 la
présidentielle a lieu en 2017
je crois que faut pas voilà à chaque
jour suffit sa peine prenons les
séquences après les autres et sur
incident travaille on travaille on
auprès des administrés c'est ce qu'il
souhaite
il souhaite pouvoir vous rencontrer vous
m comme on dit dans le rugby
un bourre-pif parfois vous féliciter
mais au moins quand vous êtes en face
d'eux vous n'êtes pas au téléphone vous
n'êtes pas dans une lettre et un
rendez-vous restée sans réponse
d'accord merci karl olive le compétiteur
je suis challenger à pau 6e merci
monsieur ferait du bien
merci à tous de votre venue en plateau